first there's only two real  conservatives let's be honest you can't  you can't be you can't be Pro BLM and  like super conservative so they gave us  four only it was really just me and  Sydney against the world shout out  Sydney and and it was actually six hours  we were there total so I don't know how  much we filmed I guess like three four  hours we were filming so maybe like hour  post hour before I don't know and that's  cut down to what an hour it was cut down  45 minutes oh yeah you can tell that  it's deeply they edited out these girls  these oh one there was a guy guy Girl  Eli on the panel biological male trans  woman I guess I didn't know any of this  before because I'm just not in the  conservative space are you familiar yes